(Music)
Open your heart to the incredible gifts
that civilization gives to us.
You flip a switch, and there is electric light.
You turn a faucet, and there is warm water and cold water,
and drinkable water.
It's a gift that millions and millions in the world
will never experience.
So these are just a few of an enormous number of gifts
to which we can open your heart.
And so I wish you that you will open your heart
to all these blessings,
and let them flow through you,
that everyone whom you will meet on this day
will be blessed by you,
just by your eyes,
by your smile,
by your touch,
just by your presence.
Let the gratefulness overflow
into blessing all around you.
(Music)
And then, it will really be
a good day.
(Applause)
Louie Schwartzberg: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)